this video is sponsored by blinkist the
app that condenses thousands of
nonfiction books into 15-minute
summaries use the link in the
description and receive one free week
and 25 off a premium membership
theodore dostoevsky is widely regarded
as one of the greatest novelists in
history his fictional work is so rich
with deep insights into human psychology
particularly its interplay with various
social and political structures of the
modern world he is equal parts renowned
psychologist and philosopher his work
brings into question how well we truly
know ourselves what we really want and
how we go about considering and
attaining these things in the world as
well as the consequences of following
false delusions and impossible ideals
his insights and warnings about humanity
both individually and collectively were
not only ahead of his time but in many
ways they are still arguably unheated
warnings immensely relevant to today
dostoevsky was born in 1821 in moscow
russia to a well-off orthodox christian
family his father was a successful
doctor and his family lived on the
hospital grounds where his father worked
while in his teens however his mother
died of tuberculosis and while
dostoevsky was away at school studying
to become an engineer his father died
without definitive cause although it was
reported and speculated that he was
murdered by his own serfs in an act of
vengeance against his abusive tendencies
young dostoevsky's proximity to the
conditions of a hospital his upbringing
in a strong faith family and the early
deaths of both his parents especially
that of the mysterious possible murder
of his father likely all culminated into
some amount of the early foundation of
what would go on to become his unique
but tragic voice as a writer
after graduating from a military
engineering institute dostoevsky would
work as an engineer however as a means
of engaging in his budding passion for
literature and humanities he also began
translating books on the side during
this time
as this passion for literature soon
increased further and further he would
resign from his engineering career and
focus solely on writing himself
in 1846 he published his first book
titled poor folk right away this work
received commercial success and was
reviewed favorably by literary critics
of the time deemed as russia's first
social novel however dostoevsky's
subsequent works just following this one
would struggle to find any similar level
of success and he soon found himself
mostly just experimenting and failing as
a writer quickly falling into financial
distress
partly as a consequence of his financial
situation in 1847 while in his late
twenties dostoevsky became associated
with a radical group of writers and
intellectuals focused on utopian
socialism this however would soon lead
him to being arrested when the
government went after those associated
with these types of groups
in 1849 as punishment dostoevsky was
sentenced to death by firing squad on
december 22nd of the same year he stood
facing the barrel of a gun pointed at
his head the remainder of his life was
now counted in minutes as the officials
held their aim and steadied to pull the
trigger suddenly at the last moment a
message arrived and dostoevsky was
pardoned
the execution would turn out to be a
mock execution used merely as a
psychological tactic to instill fear in
the prisoners
following this dostoevsky was instead
sent to siberia where he was forced to
wear grueling labor and horrible
conditions for four years
in 1860 dostoevsky returned from siberia
but returned a very different man he
would soon begin writing again but now
his voice would contain a new tone of
pessimism realism and a highly
perceptive understanding of the human
psyche he was now turned away from
utopian ideals of society and instead
his focus was now turned inward towards
spiritual and psychological explorations
over the following 20 years before dying
of a lung disorder in 1881 dostoevsky
would produce several successful
masterpieces many of which are still
regarded as some of the most important
works of literature to this day
including notes from underground crime
and punishment the idiot demons and the
brothers kara matsoff
one of the more prominent themes
established in much of dostoevsky's work
was his insights on an assessment of
human suffering more particularly the
means by which and the consequences of
humanity trying to overcome and rid
itself of suffering especially in
relation to a time in which religious
and spiritual anchors were cut loose and
individuals and societies were left to
create and defend their world views
through an increasing thrust of
rationality and technology toward the
ideal of perfect well-being
in notes from underground published in
1864 dostoevsky explores and critiques
these modern western ideals rationality
and technological progress as a means
toward perfect happiness and goodness
in the novel we follow an unnamed
retired civil servant often referred to
as the underground man through a series
of diary entries the man is deeply
angered and unhappy and he possesses a
disdain for others and the delusions in
which others live he wants to make other
people see the truth and acknowledge the
same discontent and absurdity he knows
and feels in life
for dostoevsky suffering is a
fundamental tenet of human life it is
infused in the blood thus there is no
life nor social or material condition
for life that can exist without
suffering and so for dostoevsky all
efforts and accomplishments of progress
both individually and collectively can
merely change the particular things that
we derive our suffering from but cannot
eliminate our suffering comprehensively
man only likes to count his troubles he
doesn't calculate his happiness
rotostevsky
for dostoevsky since there can never be
a social or material structure that rids
humanity of unhappiness or suffering any
objective of improving the world toward
an idealistic utopian version of itself
is doomed to fail
through the underground man dostoevsky
largely critiques and warns about
humanity pursuing these sorts of ideals
while operating within the increasingly
prevalent worldviews of nihilism
utopianism rationalism and egoism which
essentially culminate into the beliefs
that there is no inherent or
transcendent meaning to life and that
actions and morality should be based on
reason and knowledge with self-interest
as the driving force
dostoevsky argued however that with a
void of religious faith and a deeply
flawed irrational human nature this
worldview would become destructive in
the process of resolving suffering
toward perfection solutions to old
problems will inevitably create new
problems in need of new solutions and
the more grandiose the solutions the
more complex and perhaps destructive the
new problems
this is not necessarily to say that
efforts of social technological or
self-improvement are useless or
inherently bad
but rather they are not capable of
attaining what they often set out to
accomplish and if not considered within
the constraints of the human condition
their incessant motion can serve to only
fan the flames of problems
in notes from underground dostoevsky
wrote
now i ask you what can be expected of
man since he is of being endowed with
strange qualities shower upon him every
earthly blessing drown him in a sea of
happiness so that nothing but bubbles of
bliss can be seen on the surface give
him economic prosperity such that he
should have nothing else to do but sleep
eat cakes and busy himself with the
continuation of his species and even
then out of sheer ingratitude sheer
spite man would play you some nasty
trick he would even risk his cakes and
would deliberately desire the most fatal
rubbish the most uneconomical absurdity
simply to introduce into all this
positive good sense his fatal fantastic
element it is just as fantastic dreams
his vulgar folly that he will desire to
retain simply in order to prove to
himself as though that were so necessary
that men still are men and not the keys
of a piano
for dostoevsky humanity is irrational
and incessantly desires a sense of
self-agency not perfect happiness thus
even if a perfect life or society in
which happiness could be of a formulaic
ease to everyone humanity would rather
go mad or destroy its perfect conditions
than live as if it fit into a mechanical
system
we think we want happiness but we don't
not really we know this every time we
could be happy but aren't every time we
find something to dwell on or complain
about or sabotage our conscious mind
appears to tell us that we want
happiness and peace with perfect
equality but our whole being our
behaviors our history show us that we
quite often want the opposite we don't
know ourselves as well as we think and
often when we do we struggle to accept
the truth
in dostoevsky's subsequent masterpiece
crime and punishment published in 1866
he further explores this notion of
self-knowledge or the lack thereof
the novel centers around a young former
law student living in poverty named
droughtion ruskonikov raskonikov's
mother and sister are sacrificing a
great deal to try and help ruskanikov's
situation and facilitate his success his
sister even setting up to marry a
wealthy man in order to help this
however all further upsets and shames
roskonikov
additionally he is deeply affected by a
nihilistic rationalistic and atheistic
view of the world because of his views
without needing to answer to any
religious or spiritual principles
raskolnikov decides to kill and rob a
wicked abusive old pawn broker woman
whom he has become aware has a lot of
cash he believes that moral decisions
ought to be based on what one can
determine through reason produces the
highest net good on society or the
greatest happiness for the largest
number of people
because of this he believes that he
deserves the money more than the old
woman as he can do far more good with it
he can help his sister and mother and he
can become a lawyer and can then go on
to do even more good in the world
moreover he thinks of himself as an
individual of greatness powerfulness and
ruthlessness and in his mind
extraordinary men are allowed to commit
crimes for the common good and so he is
able to rationally justify murder and he
proceeds to kill the pawn broker and
then her half-sister when she walks in
during the act
throughout the rest of the novel
resconiko finds himself tormented and
riddled with guilt and horror because of
his actions he is not who he thought he
was he is not a man of ruthless power he
is a tender and feeling man
eventually he turns himself into the
police in order to essentially avoid
going insane
through raskonikov's guilt and torment
dostoevsky critiques the notion of
reason and self-interest as complete
methods of determining morality and
selfhood raskonikov had every reason to
do what he did and yet what he did was
wrong and it causes him to feel immense
pain and suffering like in notes from
underground dostoevsky is again
critiquing the views of nihilism
utilitarianism rationalism and egoism in
which all faith and relevance is placed
solely on the individual and all efforts
to maximize a life and society are done
through self-interest and rationality
also like in notes from underground
crime and punishment focuses on the
complexity of the human mind and how we
as the conscious observers and orators
of who we think we are are often
detached from and inconsistent with who
we really are
moreover our perception of who others
are is often even further removed from
the truth dostoevsky not only shows how
raskolnikov has a completely inverted
false self-perception but he also allows
the reader to relate to and empathize
with raskonikov a cold-blooded murderer
rather than purely showing how a bad
character becomes bad dostoevsky shows
how a bad character isn't purely bad and
is in many ways a lot like us
extremely confused and misguided by the
conflict of their inner psyche and their
misunderstanding of said psyche
for us all the complex interplay between
our conscious mind unconscious mind and
the world outside of ourselves is
chaotic muddled contradictory and
perhaps impossible to ever truly
understand
none of us are that far from those we
fear or dislike in them is some amount
of us and in us is some amount of them
we don't know ourselves as well as we
think we chase things that we don't want
and we often dread what we truly want we
are far less rational than we think we
exhibit a sort of madness every day in
every generation christianity and
idealistic philosophy set us up to fail
science cannot save us and technology is
not a means to escape our problems but
merely an efficient transformation of
them
dostoevsky believed all this to be the
case and arguably on at least some level
he was right however at the end of crime
and punishment raskonikov is in prison
serving just an eight-year sentence for
doing good deeds
the novel ends alluding to the prospect
that roskonikov's story will continue
suggesting dostoevsky's belief that
through suffering faith acceptance
compassion and repentance redemption is
still possible
although dostoevsky's work is largely
dark and tragic it also contains a sort
of epilogue of redemption in spite of
itself at least redemption of a sort
in his novel the idiot published in 1869
through the main character prince
michigan dostoevsky reflects on some of
his own personal experiences and ideals
in life in one instance prince mishkin
discusses an anecdote about a man
recounting having been arrested and
sentenced to a mock execution by firing
squad mirroring almost exactly
dostoevsky's own experience many years
prior
prince mishkin says
he had about five minutes left to live
not more
he said those five minutes seemed like
an endless time to him and enormous
wealth he reckoned up the time for
bidding his comrades farewell and
allotted two minutes to that then
allotted two more minutes to thinking
about himself for the last time and then
to looking around for the last time he
was dying at the age of 27 healthy and
strong
bidding farewell to his comrades he
remembered asking one of them a rather
irrelevant question and even being very
interested in the answer
then after he had bidden his comrades
farewell the two minutes came that he
had allotted to thinking about himself
he knew beforehand what he was going to
think about he kept wanting to picture
to himself as quickly and vividly as
possible how it could be like this
now he exists and lives and in three
minutes there would be something some
person or thing
but who and where
he wanted to resolve it all in those two
minutes there was a church nearby and
the top of the cathedral with its gilded
dome shown in the bright sun he
remembered gazing with terrible fixity
at that dome in the ray shining from it
it seemed to him that those were his new
nature and in three minutes he would
somehow merge with them
the ignorance of and loathing for this
new thing that would be and would come
presently were terrible yet he said that
nothing was more oppressive for him at
that moment than the constant thought
what if i were not to die what if life
were given back to me what infinity and
it would all be mine then i'd turn each
minute into a whole age i'd lose nothing
i'd reckon up every minute separately
i'd let nothing be wasted
he said that in the end this thought
turned into such anger in him that he
wished they would hurry up and shoot him
in this dostoevsky arguably alludes to
the idea that although life is so often
tragic purity and perfect goodness is
impossible and suffering is fundamental
the conscious awareness of being but
moments away from losing it all is so
overwhelmingly horrible that one would
literally rather hurry up and die than
steep in the knowledge of just how
beautiful everything truly is and that
they are just about to lose it all
forever
whether we agree with dostoevsky or not
his deep insights and brilliant works of
literature can help remind us and allow
us to feel the same beauty and depth in
life
while there's still time
this video was sponsored by blinkist
with so much stimulation and distraction
in the modern world it certainly seems
that at least for many of us it has
become more difficult to engage in
consistent and extensive reading habits
the value of learning from books however
has of course not gone down at all the
book summary app blinkist helps resolve
this problem by bridging the gap between
our sensitivity to time and the value of
learning from wide ranging collections
of books by taking the best non-fiction
books pulling out the key takeaways and
forming them into 15-minute text and
audio summaries blinkist allows you to
easily learn from and navigate across
various books and authors far more
efficiently and comprehensively spend
five minutes discovering that you are
not interested in a book not three hours
learn from 40 books on a subject not
just one refresh yourself on topics
quickly and easily blinkist provides
over 5000 titles in 27 categories as
well as summaries of popular podcasts
and a wide selection of audiobooks
meaning you can easily go straight from
summaries to audio books all in the same
place if you're interested in philosophy
blinkist has fantastic titles like
beyond good and evil by friedrich
nietzsche i am dynamite by super doe and
the story of philosophy by will durant
philosopher friedrich nietzsche once
said that dostoevsky was the only person
who has ever taught me anything about
psychology in these titles you can
discover how nietzsche as well as other
philosophers around dostoevsky's time
were influenced by him and dealt with
similar topics of suffering religious
decay and redemption use the link in the
description and you'll receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off a premium membership the free
seven-day trial can be cancelled at any
time within the trial period and of
course as always thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
my own book of my collected works on
various philosophers and philosophies
titled the art of living a meaningless
existence is also out now and you can
find the link in the description below
as well